how often do you hear about a gun and
counter-strike being Opie or breaking
the metal out the SG or the kreega's
it's commonly called is incredibly
powerful of both short and long range
it's also the latest gun to join a list
of weapons so good it's breaking the
game forever if you like winning also
there's really you just have to use it
there's really no excuses you need to be
using the creek so what's up with the
creek it's basically a scoped
alternative to the a K and deals the
most damage to armored enemies and has
the highest first shot accuracy of all
assault rifles it also has a high rate
of fire and a short reload time so on a
real note the Krieg is actually just
completely busted the rate of fire is
insane the fact that you can three shot
someone to the body with that rate of
fire is a joke and the accuracy is just
ridiculous and the best part is at 2750
it's only fifty dollars more than the
AEK to be fair it took people a long-ass
time to figure out how good the Krieg
actually was Krieg has been there all
this time like it's been right there you
could have bought it five years ago and
it will be the same like I don't care
the days buffing a bit but you know what
I mean it's like it's been there it's
just now that people start to try and
use stuff out
now the Krieg and the OGG both got a
price cut on the exact same day but
after the cata beats a major the augggh
became one of the most popular CT side
weapons while the Krieg
remained underutilized and just like the
OGG players never really bothered to
learn how to use it properly
I've watched pros it's just like
watching their streams in there they
like it looks like they want to start
practicing the creek and then they go
into a boss and they just start tapping
with it
and that like you don't need to learn
how to tap do you like your aim like you
already know how to put your crosshair
on them and shoot you know but those who
did decide to give the Krieger go sawed
pay off in huge ways as I who has to
shine through in a Woma - he's got the
bird it's gonna be fast and all they
just line up for him art with a big
triple all of them headshots is it worth
it at a point where you are two rounds
away from victory man showing his
prowess to taps whiff decreed he's
looking for one of the most brutal aces
that we've seen in recent memory oh that
looked so easy the Krieg went from a gun
barely used in pro play to one of the
most frequently used weapons on the
competitive scene despite the are being
nerfed in June the Krieg remained
untouched but Krieg is so [ __ ] busted
right now the Krieg is ridiculous right
now it's just it's too strong for the
price it's doing so much damage under
it's true thing so fast as well so it's
it's neat to be never a few players have
suggested making the Krieg
semi-automatic or removing the scope
entirely as potential changes I don't
know how you want to approach it on
maybe up the prize or nerve damage or
pen like armor penetration there's a lot
of stuff to do with it but I do like the
idea of having different guns for
different situations but as of right now
the Krieg remains unchanged and
gloriously overpowered first should be
able to take care of these no problem
fast easy and taco that will get
absolutely everyone gets the 3k spray
with the creek
while the aka is still the Teesside
darling the creek is proven to be the
more popular weapon at events over the
last few months at IEM Beijing for
example it was purchased almost twice as
often it's a we admit it's all about
abusing the creek and we just tried to
do that in the best way possible
and just because this meta isn't what
everyone's used to doesn't make it a bad
thing I think it's fun that it did
happen I think now that it needs a bit
of tuning there's a lot of stuff to do
with it but I do like the idea of having
different guns for different situations
I just wanted to be tuned a bit to a
sense where it's a situational weapon
for a certain type of strategy or play
as much as people love to complain of
Oh P gun ruining the game this is not
gonna be the last time we talk about a
weapon throwing off the balance of csgo
but let's face it with so many people
demanding that Valve nerf the gun the
Krieg meta could be at its end it's hard
to predict when or if this Krieg meta
will come to a close so if you're
queuing up for matchmaking just enjoy
that scoped goodness while you can
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]